so let me ask on this
topic because i put out that i'm talking
to you i got way more questions that i
can deal with but
what pops to minds a question somebody
asked on reddit i think is
uh please ask the dr wolfram
uh what are the specs of the computer
running the universe
so we're talking about specs of hardware
and software for simulations of a large
scale thing
what about a scale that is comparative
to
something that eventually leads to the
two of us talking and about
right right right so so actually i i did
try to estimate that
and we actually have to go a couple more
stages before we can really get to that
answer because
because we're we're talking about um uh
this
this thing i'm you know this is what
happens when you when you build these
abstract
systems and you're trying to explain the
universe
they're quite a number of levels deep so
to speak
um but uh the um you mean conceptually
or like literally because you're talking
about
smaller objects and there's yeah ten to
the it's it's twenty something
yeah right it's it's it it is
conceptually deep
and one of the things that's happening
sort of structurally in this project
is you know there were ideas there's
another layer of ideas as another
ideas to get to the different things
that correspond to
physics they're just different layers of
ideas
and they are um you know it's actually
probably if anything getting harder to
explain this project because i'm
realizing that the fraction of way
through that i am so far
and explaining this to you is less than
than you know it might be because
because we know more now
you know in the every every week
basically we know a little bit more
and like those are just layers on the
initial fundamentals
yes structure layers are you know you
you might be asking me you know
how do we get uh you know the difference
between fermions and bosons the
difference between particles that can be
all in the same state and particles that
exclude each other okay
last three days we've kind of figured
that out okay
but um and it's very interesting it's
very cool
um and it's very uh and those are some
kind of properties
at a certain level layer of abstraction
on the
graph yes and there's a and there's but
the layers of abstraction
are kind of they're compounding stacking
up so it's
difficult but it but okay but but the
specs nevertheless remain the same
the specs underneath so i i have an
estimate so the question is what are the
units so we've got these different
fundamental constants
about the world so one of them is the
speed of light
which is the so the thing that's always
the same in all these different
ways of thinking about the universe is
the notion of time
because time is computation and so
there's an elementary time
which is sort of the the the amount of
time that we ascribe
to elapsing in a in a single
computational step
yeah okay so that's the elementary time
so then there's a
parameter or whatever that is it's a
constant it's whatever we define it to
be because i mean we
we don't you know i mean it's all
relative right it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what it is because we
could be it could be slow and it's
it's just a number which which we use to
convert that to second so to speak
because we are experiencing things
and we say this amount of time has
elapsed so but we're within this thing
absolutely it doesn't yeah it doesn't
matter right right but what does matter
is the ratio
what what we can uh the ratio of the
spatial distance
and this hypograph to this uh
to this moment of time again that's an
arbitrary thing but we measure that in
meters per second for example
and that ratio is the speed of light so
the ratio of the elementary distance
to the elementary time is the speed of
light
okay perfect and so there's another
there are two other levels
of this okay so there is a thing which
we can talk about
uh which is the maximum entanglement
speed which is a thing that happens
at another level in this whole sort of
story of how these things get
constructed
um that's a sort of maximum speed in
quantum in the space of quantum
states just as the speed of light is a
maximum speed in physical space
this is a maximum speed in the space of
quantum states there's another level
which is associated with what we call
rule space which is a
another one of these maximum speeds
we'll get to this so these are
limitations on the system that are
able to capture the kind of physical
universe which we live in
the quantum mechanics they are
inevitable features of having
a a rule that has only a finite amount
of information in the rule
so long as you have a rule that only
involves a
a bounded amount a limited amount
of only involving a limited number of
elements limited number of relations
it is inevitable that there are these
speed constraints we knew about the one
for speed of light we didn't know about
the one for maximum entanglement speed
which is actually something that is
possibly measurable particularly in
black hole systems and things like this
anyway this is
long long story short you're asking what
the processing specs of the universe of
the
of this sort of computation in the
universe there's a question of even what
are the units
of some of these measurements okay so
the units i'm using are wolfram language
instructions per second okay
because you've got to have some you know
what computation are you doing
there got to be some kind of frame of
reference right right so because
it turns out in the end there will be
there's sort of an arbitrariness in the
language that you use to describe the
universe
so in those terms i think it's like
10 to the 500 or from language
operations per second i think
is the um i think it's of that order you
know so that's the scale of the
computation
what about memory if there's an
interesting thing to say about storage
and memory well there's a question of
how many sort of atoms of space might
there be
you know maybe 10 to the 400 we don't
know
exactly how to estimate these numbers i
mean this is this is based on some
some i would say somewhat rickety way of
estimating things uh you know when they
start to be able to be experiments done
if we're lucky there will be experiments
that can actually nail down some of
these numbers
and uh because of computation
reducibility
there's not much hope for very efficient
compression
like very uh efficient representation
does this
question just good question i mean
there's probably certain things you know
the fact that we can deduce anyth okay
the question is how deep does the
reduceability go
right okay and i keep on being surprised
it's a lot deeper than i thought
okay and so um one of the things is that
that there's a question of sort of how
much of the whole of physics do we have
to
be able to get in order to explain
certain kinds of phenomena like for
example
if we want to study quantum interference
do we have to know what an electron
is turns out i thought we did turns out
we don't
i thought to know what energy is we
would have to know what electrons were
we don't get a lot of really powerful
shortcuts
right there's a there's a bunch of sort
of bulk information about the world
the the thing that i'm excited about
last few days okay
is um uh the idea of fermions versus
bosons fundamental idea that i mean it's
the
the reason we have matter that doesn't
just self-destruct
is because of the exclusion principle
that means that
two electrons can never be in the same
quantum state
you